when you wrote about in the book i i
think this might have been a big
betrayal in your life that
here you are you get famous and then you
turn on the tv and your mom is on tv
with hard copy and she's giving a tour
of your house and she's pointing out
that this is the bed where you lost your
virginity
did you stop talking to your mom at that
point for a couple of years i mean did
you say enough i i mean this is
ridiculous
uh eight years eight years i was calling
my mom at that time after i'd gotten
famous needing to talk to my mom because
trying to figure out hey
i'm a little unbalanced here these
things are going on what do they mean
and my mom
was not the only one that was on the
phone most of the woman that was on the
phone was a fan
of my fame and so i would have
conversations
and then all of a sudden what we talked
about shows up in the paper three days
later what mom that was between us oh
i didn't think you know what's fine no
no no no mom don't share that this is a
new thing
loose lips can sink my ship you know and
in that one we had to talk and all of a
sudden i'm at home and i get a call from
a buddy and are you watching this i said
what they go turn on the hard copy
there's mom giving somebody to tour
through the house
here's where i caught him so-and-so in
bed here's where i saw him in the shower
you know what he was doing in there
[Music]
and i call her up and i go mom what'd
you do and she goes what are you talking
about
i go hardcover she goes what are you
talking about i go mom i can hear it on
the other end of the phone i'm watching
it you're watching it too she's like oh
that
i didn't think you'd find out
i'm like oh it's national television mom
so we went through a time where i didn't
really
share much with her because you had to
set boundaries and that's the biggest
betrayal of all because
your mom is the one person at least you
wish that your mom would be perfect and
always be on your side i mean that's the
stuff of fame that's really hard to deal
with all of a sudden
you're opening your eyes and seeing your
mother for who she really is it's tough
she really is but because she was always
still my mom but she became a different
person
look nobody is perfect this was
something that was out of the realm of a
relationship that my mother's ever
had i've forgiven her it wasn't her it
wasn't
her fault i mean i just had to
put make some boundaries and it was a
strenuous relationship for eight years
we're back completely now once i got my
career sort of stable and felt on my
feet i let go of the range and said go
get it mom
whatever you want there's the camera and
she's been awesome
she's got incredible stuff to say and do
and i'm like go for it
there's always forgiveness i just tried
to bide my time and it was a sad time i
remember talking to my brothers going i
have these five minute conversations
with mom on sunday when i'll call her
and
i just really listen and barely say
anything and i don't feel like she's
getting to know me or i'm getting to
know her any better
you know it was tough for eight years
but we went through it and we're on the
other side of it it's good